i think too
a lot of people who would be in your
position because you obviously you
compared so much to pop smoke who's
from your from your area you guys sold
you guys went to elementary school
together you guys are from the same hood
like i think that
a lot of people would run from that but
i feel like you've paid a lot of respect
and also have taken take on the
challenge
of saying yes you know maybe i was
inspired by pop
of course but at the same time i'ma show
you i'm my own dude
you know what i'm saying inspirations is
all around you and then you should look
to them
as motivation nothing less nothing more
for me like
i watch other people portray you know
like
certain things like yeah we was this we
was that and no actually using that for
clout you trying to get your own name up
based off another
person now i'm paying my respects but do
like i said my work
ethic and my drive you're gonna see how
we separate how we differ
yeah well but actually we wanted the
same throw me floss or die one way in no
way out [ __ ] know that
there it is man there yeah for people
who don't know your area canarsie is an
area that
um is probably one of the least known
outside of new york you know we're in la
we here at brooklyn we know what
brownsville is we know what
yeah but i feel like canarsie probably
has gotten the least amount
he was overlooked for a long time yeah
and we was doing we was the ones getting
most of the money
from me we was once behind a lot of
other [ __ ] too but
you know [ __ ] kept that low profile
like i said pop brought us to the light
from me he said well look these [ __ ]
over here giving it up the same way
[ __ ] is over there
and feel me and we just i'm just another
person who gonna prove that